hey 42 here when you think of the
coolest people who ever lived it's hard
to beat the Cowboys of the old west
pretty much everything about that is
utterly iconic imagine spending your
days Crossing epic Vistas and going on
the hunt for Curly's gold before hitting
the local Saloon to cheated cards and
get into gunfights all before tipping
your 10 gallon hat to the nearest
prostitute and clip clopping away into
another perfect Sunset it certainly
beats a stressful commute followed by
eight hours of Microsoft Excel
the quintessential Wild West period
started at the end of the American Civil
War in 1865 and ended with the official
closing of the frontier by the U.S
Census Bureau in 1895. though some
scholars believe the wild west was
briefly reopened by Will Smith in 1999.
during the late 19th century thousands
of settlers were crossing the U.S in
search of Fortune and glory on the New
Frontier it's during this period that we
first hear many of the names that still
live on in infamy 150 years later like
the legendary Hunter and impresario
Buffalo Bill legendary Lawman Wyatt Earp
and Sharpshooter Calamity Jane but of
all the famed folk and Felons of the old
west there was not a fellow more
fearsome than James Butler Hickok a man
who so epitomized a wild west that he
was actually nicknamed Wild Bill
Christmas came early this year because I
got gifted the new performance package
by manscapes let's check it out the
lawnmower 4.0 waterproof cordless
trimmer is built with Advanced Skin safe
technology which helps to reduce Nicks
and cuts on your most sensitive areas
and it has this really cool LED light
which is really helpful for grooming on
those cold dark winter nights and for a
stocking stuffer for you there's a crop
preserver board deodorant and the crop
reviver bull toner spray
this stuff is a game changer new to the
collection is the weed whacker nose and
ear hair trimmer now I didn't know that
I needed this so badly but let me tell
you I'm glad Santa hooked me up every
guy out there needs to add manscape to
their wish list this season or if you've
got a special man in your life that's
been extra good this year make sure you
get him the performance package by
manscapes and for a limited time you'll
also get two free gifts the shed travel
bag and the manscaped high performance
anti-chafing boxer briefs that's a gift
on top of a gift so don't wait around go
to
manscape.com42 to get 20 off plus free
international shipping plus two free
gifts your jingle balls will thank you
and thanks to manscapes for sponsoring
this video
born in 1837 into a household where guns
were as normal as milk and potatoes Bill
became an excellent Marksman at an early
age he lived with his family on a farm
in rural Illinois a few hours from
Chicago the area was Rife for gangs of
Outlaws collectively known as Prairie
Bandits and being good with a six
shooter was an important life skill no
matter how old you were
but whilst an early exposure to guns and
ammo was par for the course the fact
that his father William was an active
abolitionist was rather more unusual the
family home was a station on the
so-called Underground Railroad a network
of routes and safe houses used by slaves
to escape to states where slavery was
illegal Bill's father was tragically
killed because of his stance on
abolition when Bill was just 15 and it
had a big impact on the young man's life
both Bill's parents were devout Baptists
and although it seems their religious
views didn't quite rub off on their
pistol toting infant their activism
around slavery certainly did as 18 he
moved to what was then called the Kansas
territory to join an anti-slavery
vigilante group known as the jayhawkers
it was there that he met a cocky 12 year
old scout by the name of William Cody
though you probably know him as Buffalo
Bill one of the most famous figures from
the old west
their paths would cross again soon but
not before both had become Living
Legends
the next job on Wild Bill hickok's Wild
West resume was working for a stagecoach
company at the time driving a
horse-drawn coach cross country was
fraught with all kinds of dangers as
bill would soon discover in 1860 he was
driving from Missouri to New Mexico when
he was attacked not by Bandits but a
bear as occupational hazards go it
wasn't the kind of thing that would
typically be covered in the company
handbook and for most of us it would
have meant a Grizzly end but not for
Bill Against All Odds he managed to take
on two tons of ursine aggression and
come out on top killing the bear with
his bare hands okay he had a knife too
but the inaccuracy was worth it for the
pun after his unofficial audition for
the Revenant bill was left badly injured
his chest shoulder and arm severely
crushed it took him mumps in bed
convalescing before he was well enough
to work again and when he was he was
sent by his employers to a stagecoach
station Rock Creek Nebraska and it was
there that he sealed his reputation as a
man you most certainly did not want to
[ __ ] with
local landowner David McConnells took a
disliking to Bill giving him the
nickname duck bill on account of his
long nose I can only assume McConnell
didn't know that the man he was mocking
had recently kicked seven shades of [ __ ]
out of a bear
McConnell's and two of his buddies plus
McConnell's 12 year old son ambushed
Bill Hickok whilst he was working and
things quickly escalated exactly what
happened next varies depending on which
source you read but the end result is
all the same a gunfight leaves three men
dead and Bill very much alive
I should probably point out that the 12
year old child was physically unharmed
in the melee deeply traumatized but
physically unharmed
bill was acquitted of the murders as it
was believed he'd acted in self-defense
and it's at this point that the legend
of Wild Bill really starts to take shape
the shooting of the three men in Rock
Creek soon became Legend and there's
legendary Tales often are over the years
this one was embellished for dramatic
effect
by the time the story appeared in half
his monthly magazine it sounded like
something out of a Sylvester Stallone
film I'm not one of the modern ones with
acting and emotions and all that one of
those 80s films where he just machine
guns everybody he meets for an hour and
a half straight in this fluffed up Fable
now known as the McConnell's Massacre
Bill took down 10 bloodthirsty
Desperados of just a revolver and a
knife sustaining 11 bullet wounds and 13
knife wounds in the process shortly
after the American Civil War broke out
in April 1861 Bill joined the Union Army
of the north and it was there that he
earns the name by which people would
refer to him for generations to come so
what exactly do you have to do to become
known as wild during what was
indisputably one of History's craziest
periods well in one famous incident bill
is said to have dispersed an angry mob
intent on hanging a bartender by firing
into the air and then just basically
staring everyone down
until they went away
no doubt that took some balls but I
suppose when you've wrestled an actual
real-life bear a few disgruntled humans
hardly registers however the name of
wild bill came about it stuck which I'm
sure Bill preferred to being compared to
a dog
after leaving the Army in June 1865 bill
made his way to Springfield Missouri
and within a month he got involved in
another shootout which would further
burnish his bad boy reputation
and this one turned out to be a stone
cold old west classic his opponent was
Davis Tutt and the two men had fallen
out over a dispute over a gambling loan
to cut a long story short Bill owed
taught money and when Bill failed to pay
Tut took his prized gold pocket watch
instead Bill's Pride was already wounded
by this incident and when foot started
flaunting that watch all over town he
quickly learned that you can't humiliate
a bear-killing sharp shooting War
veteran whose first name is wild and
expect to get away with it
the two men glanced each other across
the Town Square and both adopted the
classic Quick Draw stand so familiar to
us today from westerns at this point I
like to think a tumbleweed blew across
the square a frightened Saloon owner
pulls the shutters closed and an Old
Prospector dropped his bottle of
moonshine and got the hell out of there
both men Drew at a distance of 75 yards
when the dust had settled Davis Tut was
dead
whether or not Bill did that thing where
you spin the gun on your finger before
putting it back in the holster we don't
know but let's just say that he almost
definitely certainly did this quick draw
shootout now so familiar to us thanks to
Hollywood is rumored to have been the
first of its kind in history
two days later bill was arrested for
murder reduced her manslaughter before
his trial began it should have been an
open and shut case but only four
Witnesses had actually seen the fight
and they couldn't all agree on exactly
what had happened in the end bill was
acquitted once again much to the horror
of many and he left a court a free man
several weeks later he was interviewed
by journalist George Nichols the man
credited with spreading the Wild Bill
Legend after he wrote an article about
the gunfighter for Harper's magazine now
Nichols was basically the 19th century
version of Kim Jong-un spin doctor
in the article he claimed Bill had
killed hundreds of men and with such a
dead eye shot that he could put Six
Bullets into a Target no bigger than a
human heart from 50 yards bill would
spend the next few years working as an
army Scout including working for General
Costa who achieved old west infamy
himself by Leading a spectacularly
unsuccessful offensive at the Battle of
Little Bighorn commonly known as
Custer's Last Stand despite his shall we
say volatile personality it was always
Bill's ambition to be on the right side
of the law and in 1869 he was elected
Marshall of the city of Hayes and
Sheriff of Ellis County both of which
are in Kansas with a badge on his chest
bill was soon back doing what he did
best making caps pop and bodies drop in
only his first month as Sheriff he
really hit the ground running by killing
two men in Cold Blood and the year later
he was involved in another gunfight
wounding one man and killing another
after they pinned him to the floor in a
saloon brawl
in 1871 Bill moved to Abilene becoming
Marshall once again but it was to be his
last posting as a Lawman after a dispute
that began with a bull's erection ended
in tragedy and yes you did hear that
correctly The Bullying question could be
found on the sign of a saloon in Abilene
called the Bull's Head
and it had been depicted shall we say
standing proudly to attention as a kind
of 19th century marketing stunt cooked
up by the saloon's owners famous old
west businessman philco and renowned
Gunslinger Ben Thompson some of the
town's folk were less than happy to see
this
um Raging Bull on full display in public
although I'm not sure why every town
needs a USP and the Abilene Bulls Wang
is perfect for tempting tourists still
Wild Bill asked a saloon's owners to
tone down their bovine pornography just
a bit and when they refused he took the
bull by the horns well penis and changed
it anyway
the argument came to a head on October
the 5th Co was celebrating the end of
Castle season by firing off a couple of
shots from his pistol that man really
had a thing for cows didn't he
Marshall Bill was summoned to see what
all a commotion was about and Co claimed
he'd been shooting at a stray dog which
was not only legal in Abilene it was
encouraged to the point where people
were given 50 cents for every stray they
shot but Phil was clearly skeptical
because he ordered that Kobe arrested
rather than come quietly cow the cow
lover drew his pistols
Badger no badge while bill was a man who
met violence with violence and in the
ensuing gunfight he shot co twice in the
stomach the wounds would prove fatal
three days later by now Wild Bill's
Wicked Quick Draw was renowned in every
town but as many of you will already
know sometimes unloading too quickly can
be a bad thing in the confusion of the
fight with Co Bill's Deputy had rushed
in to help but Bill mistook the man for
an attacker and thanks to those rapid
reflexes of his he shot and killed his
Brave colleague before he even knew what
he was doing bill was understandably
stripped of his position as Marshall and
he left Abilene shortly afterwards this
act of manslaughter is said to have
haunted him for the rest of his days and
he was never involved in another gun
fight for as long as he lived
after such a tragedy an attempted career
in Showbiz might seem like an unlikely
Next Step but in a life as bizarre as
bills you shouldn't rule anything out in
1873 he was approached by that Plucky
Scout he'd met in his younger days
William Cody who'd spent the intervening
years forging a legend of his own and
was now touring with Wild West themed
shows as Buffalo Bill Buffalo asked Bill
Wilde if he'd like to join him and the
equally awesomely named Texas Jack I'm a
hundredo in a production called the
Scouts of the Prairie Wild Bill agreed
but it turned out he wasn't really made
for the Limelight and when I say not
made for the Limelight what I really
mean is that he used to hide behind the
scenery and once responded to a
spotlight being shot on him by shooting
it off the ceiling yeah he left after
only a few months he drifted for a few
years played by deteriorating eyesight
and with little money to his name not
that it was all doom and gloom it was
around this time he met the woman he'd
eventually marry Agnes Thatcher Lake had
lived her life every bit as exciting as
bills she was a former tightrope Walker
whose first husband ran a circus when
he'd been shot and killed while
subjecting A customer from the Big Top
Agnes had taken over the business she
was over a decade older than Bill and
already had a daughter but the team also
felt like kindred spirits and they
married in March 1876.
though Bill left Agnes not long
afterwards to try and make his fortune
looking for gold in South Dakota
say what you want about the man he
bloody loved an adventure but like all
Adventures bills had to come to an end
sometime and it was in the aptly named
town of Deadwood that he penned his
final chapter on the 1st of August 1876
he was playing poker in Nettle and man's
famous Saloon when he was shot in the
back of the head by fellow Gambler Jack
McCall who'd lost heavily to bill in a
poker game the day before bill was shot
at point-blank range and the bullet
passed through his score
proving that even in death he was a
danger to others the hand of cards Bill
held when he died was A Pair of Aces and
a pair of eights all black and this has
since become known as the dead man's
hand in the century and a half since
Bill died there have been numerous books
written about him and he's been
portrayed many times over in films and
TV it seems no matter what else changes
we still love our cowboys wild and wild
bill was surely the wildest of them all
thanks for watching